President of the European Parliament
vice-president of the Commission
distinguished leaders of the political
groups members of the parliaments my
fellow Europeans firstly let me express
my appreciation for all the efforts and
the work during this electoral period
and the progress that you have achieved
for Europe and us all but of course my
focus today will not be on our past but
on our future I believe that we must
step up to defend our fundamental values
in the European Union and the most
strategic way to fight the forces that
challenge those values is to deliver
results in the areas of employment
security migration climate change and
thus to create hope for the future so
that should be our core missions the
defence of our democratic values and our
young people's dream there are people
that say that idealism is the preserve
of the young and that when we enter into
the world of adults we learned that
nothing is black and white and realize
that self-interest and cynical trade-off
rules the world I believe that now that
narrative is wrong my parents took me in
as a foster child they taught me about
shared responsibilities about respect
for every human being about solidarity
and during my both trade union and
political life as an adults I have had
to compromise and make tough decisions
in difficult situations such as economic
downturns but also terror attacks
that has not made me forget my values it
has only deepened my belief in the
importance of having a moral compass to
guide you through these tough times
because if we didn't let our values
steer our decisions if it didn't feel
that our choices were leading us towards
the kind of society we believe in what
would be the point in making decisions
at all now the same applies to the
European Union our union is based on
values the whole idea of creating a
common market and joint responsibility
for coal and steel production was to tie
our countries and the people closer
together we wanted to fulfill Frieda
Schiller sentiments in wood of joy that
Alamance invadin breeder with equal
rights equal value and which put to the
music of Beethoven became our common
anthem and now that our union has grown
in size and has grown older as well we
just like the individual need to
remember our most fundamental values for
what would be the ultimate points of our
work the ultimate point of our union if
we did not promote the values that we
believe in
and this my friends may also be the best
thing we can do for the world we are
living in a time when the multilateral
system is being shaken to its core the
United Kingdom wants to leave our union
the transatlantic link is being
questioned meanwhile China is on the
rise and several economies in Southeast
Asia and Africa are ready to follow in
its footsteps and redraw the entire
global economic map and at the same time
Russia is acting in a revansch AIST
manner in flagrant contempt of
international law so now more than ever
it is time to stand up for common
principle based solutions and a world
order where might does not come before
right
but the EU can only be a strong voice
for democracy in the world if all of us
member states send up for the principles
of democracy also at home we can only be
a credible actor in the Middle East if
we fight anti-semitism and Islamophobia
in our own countries we can only be a
force for free media and the rule of law
in our neighborhood if we have a free
media and independent courts in our
Union for every democratic principle
that is weakened in the EU the EU voice
in the world will be equally weakened
and therefore therefore the EU must
stand up for our fundamental values both
externally in our world but also of
course internally in our Union and this
is more than about our place in the
world this is about the whole future of
our cooperation if the principles
contained in our most fundamental
contracts are not adhere to how are we
then to trust other agreements all the
single market on free movement
everything that does so much for our
prosperity if our promises to each other
are to be trusted
if our cooperation and our economy are
to continue to grow
then pacta sunt serve and I must apply
to the most fundamental contracts
contracts of all and therefore Sweden
will work to defend the --use core
values in the budget negotiations in our
support of the Commission's work and my
government will propose to the swedish
parliament that sweden will join the
european public prosecutor's office to
contribute in the fight against
corruption and the investment of EU
funds
we support also the Belgium proposal or
something similar to establish an EU
mechanism for the peer review of
adherence to the rule of law and I will
devote my efforts in Europe to defending
the values that I have borne since my
childhood of the equal value of all
people and of solidarity I will give my
all side-by-side with so many of you to
refute and fight the extremist forces
who deny these values and those forces
that are doing everything they can to
tear apart the Union that defend them
and of course EU is a compromise
probably one of the most successful
compromises in world history but there
can be no compromising on human dignity
there is no reasonable level of
anti-semitism no acceptable level of
racism no tolerable level of misogyny or
homophobia never would we compromise on
these values
[Applause]
the defense of democracy is also the
defense of young people's dreams is
there anything more dangerous to society
than its young people ceasing to dream
it is in societies that have lost hope
that both political and religious
extremism can grow the strongest and
this is not only crucial in the fight
against extremism but also in the world
to uphold a broad popular support for
our union I believe it is crucial for
all of us in the current brexit
negotiations for example that the UK and
the EU have the ability to move on as
friends and create a close strong and
long-term relationship but the only way
for the EU to avoid similar exit ordeals
in the future is to constantly prove its
worth to people's everyday lives and to
their dreams for the future and that is
why the EU should not only benefit the
market but preferably benefit its people
it is also why the work for a larger
market can also be the work for stronger
democracy if that can create jobs and
hope for our young people
over the past two years South African
president cyril ramaphosa and i have
co-chaired a global Commission on the
future of work for the International
Labor Organization and there is no doubt
that the in the future work will be more
advanced more autumn eyes more digitized
and that demand for skilled workers was
soar and this is good news for EU we
benefit from a global competition that
is based on knowledge rather than lower
wages but we cannot rest on our laurels
because everyone wants to be in the same
position China has long been educating
more engineers than the United States
Germany and Japan put together so in
this respect our European cooperation
will have an incredibly important role
to play in the creation and sharing a
world leading knowledge and innovation
and there are always many competing
interests in budget negotiations you
know that better than most but my
country has learned that the very hard
way that it is only with strict polish
priorities and a budget that is under
control that democracy actually can
deliver in the long term and with
stability and that is why given all the
competing interests we do not propose a
larger budget but rather the stronger
prioritization of innovation new jobs
the digital digital educational and
physical infrastructure required to make
them possible it is our responsibility
for our young people's dreams to take
advantage of this opportunity
our solution can never be to lower wages
or raise protectionist walls we should
not
our selves off from the world we should
lead it now therefore I am proud also
that young people now in Tallinn over in
Bratislava can listen to hip-hop from
Paris or fado from Lisbon on Spotify
from Stockholm but I also know how hard
Spotify had to work to get launched in
Europe compare that to a startup company
in Silicon Valley that can launch a
product on the US market and reach more
than 320 million people immediately so
our only chance of competing with this
is to make it just as easy to reach all
the citizens in the European Union at
the same time
and believe me anyone who has lived
through a dark Nordic winter knows that
we can not compete with California when
it comes to weather
generations people from our continent
have traveled across the Atlantic in
search of a better life
but the John genus is an IT geniuses of
today in the future should not have to
go west or east for that matter to
realize their dreams they should be able
to do so here in Europe in a digital
market open to everyone
France it is now almost a treat to visit
the European Commission website and see
that one priority policy area is the
European pillar of social rights of
course my pride is not diminished when I
also say says that we launched this work
in the Swedish state of Gothenburg
now I'm grateful to president Juncker
the Commission to the European
Parliament to the member states in the
council for all of our work to create a
social pillar and established 20 key
principles that strengthen the social
rights of all the citizens of Europe but
no worker will or should thank us unless
these 20 principles also become a
reality across the EU until we stand up
for collective agreements and fair wages
until we put a stop to rule breaking and
tax fraud until we secure gender
equality and women's right to a full
wage a career without glass ceilings and
the freedom to the side of their own
lives
now for this very same reason Sweden
will actively promote new free trade
agreements because we know how many jobs
these agreements can create but all
these agreements should also be
favorable to people as well as to the
market the agreements must respect our
environment our health and the rights of
workers
an enormous potential for the European
services market if it's opened up and
shaped with concern for social rights
the EU labor market must be defined by
all of the positive freedoms the freedom
of study aboard abroad learn languages
work throughout Europe but never the
freedom to set workers against workers
our common labor market our common labor
market should not crush workers dreams
it should fulfill them
know that if you are to have hope in the
future
you must also feel safe here and now
Isis and terrorism are dreadful security
threats that must be dealt with together
but unfortunately that's not only not
the only challenge that we have I
recently met the leadership of Europol
at their headquarters in The Hague and
their virtual command post Europol has
done an amazing job not least breaking
up and arresting paedophile networks
this type of crime every nation a
nation's police service can see their
part but we can only see the whole and
crush it in cooperation with others a
single nation would not even if it
really wanted to
even if it poured in resources be able
to solve that alone
so Europe is borderless for criminals as
well they read up the European laws
looking for the weakest national
legislation and for the new national
markets to enter and that is why Sweden
wants to deepen European efforts to
fight organized crime as well as cyber
threats we want to strengthen our
cooperation on security and defence
increase our ability to implement joint
civilian and military crisis management
operations and have a European Union
that cooperates with strategic partners
and build security together I also know
that there is a broad agreement in this
Parliament and on this continent that
the EU must never again lose control in
the way it did during the refugee crisis
chaotic migration affects the confidence
of the whole of society and reception of
refugees but it affects the refugees
themselves worst of all the only ones
who benefits are right-wing extremists
who are able to use the situation to
inflame hatred of migrants the EU s free
movement of people requires shared
external borders and a shared
responsibility for orderly and regulated
migration built on three pillars
strong cooperation with countries
outside the EU so that fewer people are
displaced and more people can have
better living conditions so that new
migration crisis can be reduced or
prevented entirely secondly the control
of all external border which is now
taking place to the strengthening of
Frontex creating greater security and
saving lives thirdly the fair
distribution of those who arrive and
whose grounds for asylum are to be
examined with that work carried out as a
shared responsibility by all Member
States it should not be possible to
benefit from all of the advantages of
the Schengen cooperation and then
refused to share the responsibility for
its maintenance and we have in this
respect a huge task task ahead of us
Sweden will do its best to support the
completion of that task and I'm under no
illusion that it will be simple but if
we fail to deliver the Schengen
Agreement will be weakened and in the
long run so will the entire European
Union so it's time now to step up for
orderly and regulated migration in
Europe it is in the best interest of us
all dear friends as Swedes we're often
asked do you know ABBA
do you know Slaton Ibrahimovic now we're
getting ready for a new question junot
agree attitude by we're proud of the
demonstrations that she has inspired
which gathered over a million young
people all over the world but one thing
we must never forget in their message is
the following it is not up to their
generation to solve the climate crisis
it is up to us all generations here and
now the Swain is ready to be in the lead
of that work and show what is possible
we have a climate framework for our
society which will lead our efforts to
cut emissions quickly and powerfully and
achieve achieve net zero emissions by
2045 but it's us together that must
implement the Paris agreement without
any ifs without any buts without maybes
in order to keep the global temperature
rise below 1.5 degrees and as part of
this work the EU need to adopt a goal of
net zero emissions by 2050 at the very
latest and this is also a great
opportunity for European industry as a
whole world is crying out for new
solutions so this is not only the right
thing to do morally it is the smart
thing to do economically and it is
crucial to our survival to conclude mr.
president this is what I want to say to
you today idealism is not only the
preserve of the young our common values
have been the basis for the --use
fantastic history and they must guide us
now so that we can have an even brighter
future and at these times when people
say that the EU must prove its worth
there is no better task for our Union
than defending our democratic values and
by delivering on jobs security migration
and climate change defending the dreams
of our young people an EU that can
deliver this
not only gains greater legitimacy but
also a stronger voice in our world it is
indeed a difficult task but that is why
it's so alluring and that is why it's so
perfect for us thank you for listening
[Applause]
thank you very much it's a prime
minister thank you for a speech for your
proposal on the future European Union
your engagement now we need to close the
electronic registration for the catch
the eye the next speaker is the vice
president of the European Commission mr.
Boddy's Dombrowski's the other fro
honorable president Ayane honorable
Prime Minister honourable members it's a
great pleasure to represent president
Younker in this debate on the future of
our union with Prime Minister Levin at
the start of next year we will celebrate
25 years of Sweden taking its rightful
place at the heart of our union in this
time a Sweden has brought so much to the
European Union from its rich culture to
its unique social model in many ways a
Swedish way of doing things has become
both an example and a guide for our
future Sweden is a country that does
more than simple talk about European
values it puts them right at the heart
of its society through its strong social
protection and high-quality education
and health care for all and it is
country that always looks forward
for instance Sweden was one of the first
countries to pass a climate act with an
explicit goal of being carbon neutral by
2045 it is also well ahead of the curve
when it comes to embracing a new digital
world Stockholm has is now home to more
1 billion plus companies or so-called
unicorns per capita anywhere in the EU
the most important tech hub of this kind
outside the Silicon Valley we can learn
from all of this but as we look forward
there is another Swedish concept that I
believe should be central to the future
of our union for many Swedes lagoon is a
lifestyle and a habit of mind it is a
Swedish philosophy of moderation and
balance of avoiding both excess and
extreme and for many it is a secret of a
balanced sustainable and happy life as
we look to our future Europe should
inspire itself from Livan to find the
right balance for all of its member
states and all of its citizens
it means focusing on the things that
matter most to Europeans and doing less
else
it means tackling the big issues by
being open to compromise and find
balanced solutions to common challenges
in this spirit I want to commend the
Prime Minister and all of Sweden for the
way they responded to the migration
crisis in 2015 and ever since it has
been leading efforts on a long-term and
comprehensive reform of our Asylum
system so that it offers the protections
force on those who need so the solution
we need must balance solidarity and
responsibility as the Commission has put
as a package of asylum reform on the
table and Europeans now expect their
leaders to make real progress and we
count on Sweden to continue leading
those efforts
Sweden has also been at the forefront of
efforts to make our union more socially
fair for
an issue which is a second nature to
your country
I want to sense the Prime Minister and
his for his personal readership on the
European pillar of social rights
launched by President Juncker in
Guttenberg in 2017 it is a shared and
future proof commitment to support a
fairer and more equal society across
Europe once again it's about finding the
right balance this is of course mainly a
national competence and EU does not
interfere with a crucial role played by
the social partners but there is a lot
we can do together and thanks to the
social pillar we already have we have
ensured equal pay for equal work in the
same place in recent months we have
agreed new rules to improve work-life
balance for work-life balance for
parents and carers we have agreed to set
up a European labor authority to make
the labor market fairer and support the
17 million Europeans who work in another
member state and we are investing in
skills to help people get on the job
market or find new opportunities in
today's rapidly changing world of work
honourable members when it comes to the
future of our union there is no more
important priority than the fight
against climate change millions of young
Europeans in Europe and growingly
beyond Europe are marching politicians
at least European politicians are
listening to the young people they tell
us that every year of their lives has
been one of the warmest recorded indeed
17 out of 18 hottest years on record all
occurred in this century and we see with
our own eyes the damage that this is
causing we saw they were stating forest
fires and hugely costly droughts in
Sweden and elsewhere last summer and
just recently we had another tragic
reminder of this in Mozambique Malawi
and Zimbabwe sadly this is not a freak
event or a one-off
by 2050 climate change could force more
than 10 persons
of the global population to flee their
homes the world needs to respond and
Europe needs to continue leading the way
we did that with Paris agreement which
we are implementing at home and helping
others to do the same right across the
world for example the European
Commission has already proposed to
devote a quarter of u.s. budget to
climate related action as of 2021
but public finance alone will not be
enough to meet our ambitious climate and
energy targets by 2030 say financial
sector needs to play its part in fight
against climate change this is why we
put forward an action plan on
sustainable finance to incentivize
private capital to flow towards green
projects and we immediately followed up
with three legislative proposals two of
which have already been agreed at EU
level but fighting climate change takes
more than targets and it will not stop
in 2030 we must look further ahead this
is why the Commission has set a
long-term strategy to be climate neutral
by 2050 according to our estimates this
would lead to clean technology solutions
and boost our GDP by up to 2% and take
off as much as 3 trillion euros from our
energy import bill while ensuring a just
and socially balanced transition flow it
is good for people and it's good for the
economy and for me that is what European
leadership looks like in 21st century
the world expects and we must deliver
this is why we have focused our
proposals was a new multi-annual
financial framework on areas where
European action can have the biggest
impact to respond to the future
challenges the commission has proposed a
modest increase in our long-term budget
to an equivalent of 1 point 11 percent
of --use 27 gni we hope that Member
States will support this approach which
is a minimum to find our to fund our
joint European actions as Sweden for
example has long to call for we have
put forward programs that are modern
flexible and focused and we are
investing where there is a greatest
potential for our future funding for
research and innovation will be
increased by 50% to reach hundred
billion euros a new digital Europe
program worst nine billion euro will
support Europe digital transformation
and create new opportunities for Swedish
tech companies to flourish like Spotify
or Claro
and as I mentioned we will ensure that
25% of the budget will support our
climate and sustainable development
targets there is no greater return on
investment than a clean pollinate for
future generations dear Prime Minister
honourable members it is only by working
together to make our union stronger that
we can collectively tackle the issues
which individually we never could the
last 25 years of a Swedish man a
membership of the European Union should
be our template it shows that a stronger
more sovereign Europe means a stronger
more sovereign Sweden and it shows the
virtues of showing true responsibility
and solidarity as we look to our future
this should they should inspire us to
help us to find the balance set love
that we need in our union thank you very
much